would you like me to introduce everybody
before you mr. Killa Kissimmee Lucas
that's Kenny you can convince anyone
pretty much anything
yeah the round mound no what do you want
to say now you just sit at home and your
grandma's basement with the drawers on
type it on your damn keyboard shut the
hell up
this is the pisses come back what the
hell was that was that thing over there
the whole time
yes it was just grab a little edge of
the beat this will see this gotta be B
and the little baby man what did I tell
y'all about that
and I came prepared tonight don't you
want to weigh in on this this is
truckster apparently train tunnel is way
out of studio j4 a day off tomorrow if
you love basketball you gotta stay over
there that's still living that what you
would say has no chance of happening to
black guys be the black gap that's let's
stop not on here man America and they
just tell you something because that do
not commit crimes we checked the place
nobody's up on my stuff - Mary okay that
is not a European cut
one of the greatest of all time I don't
want to see those huh gonna kiss and
sing Kumbaya
I want work room by oh is that the remix
Kimmy don't we in the playoffs it's come
by that's why I hate working here man